in the contrary law as the inversion of
the first law or the inner difference it
is true that infinity itself becomes the
object of the understanding but once
again the understanding fall short of
infinity as such since it again
apportions to two worlds or to two
substantial elements that which is a
difference in it self the self repulsion
of the self same and the self attraction
of the unlike to the understanding the
movement as it is founded experience is
here a mere happening and the self same
in the unlike our predicate whose
essence is an inert substrate what is
for the understanding an object to the
sensuous cover it is for us in its
essential form as a pure notion this the
apprehension of the difference as it is
in truth or the apprehension of infinity
as such is for us or in itself that is
merely implicit the exposition of its
notion belongs to science but
consciousness in the way that it
immediately has this notion again comes
on the scene as a form belonging to
consciousness itself or as a new shape
of consciousness which does not
recognize and what has gone before its
own essence but looks on it as something
quite different
since this notion of infinity is an
object for consciousness the latter is
consciousness of a difference that is no
less immediately cancelled consciousness
is for its own self it is a
distinguishing of that which contains no
difference or self consciousness I
distinguish myself from myself and in
doing so I am directly aware that what
is distinguished for myself is not
different from me I the self same being
repelled myself from myself but what is
positive is distinct from me or as
unlike me is immediately in being so
distinguished not a distinction for me
it is true that consciousness of an
other of an object in general is
necessarily self consciousness a
reflectiveness into self consciousness
of itself in its other nests the
necessary advance from the previous
shapes of consciousness for which their
truth was a thing and other than
themselves expresses just this that not
only is consciousness of a thing
possible only for self God for a self
consciousness
but that self consciousness
alone is the truth of those shapes but
it is only for us that this truth exists
not yet for consciousness but
self-consciousness has at first become
simply for itself now yet as a unity
with consciousness in general
paragraphs 164 and 165 are going to
close out this section of force in the
understanding this very complex as
you've seen section of the phenomenology
following the original dialectic of
sense certainty and then going into this
dialectic of perception and then
introducing all sorts of other more
complicating factors like the notion of
force and the reciprocity of forces the
notion of law the whole idea of the
inverted world and the reincorporation
of these these different worlds into
each other all of which has been carried
out by the understanding which is
consciousness and this is going to bring
a close to the entire section
consciousness in moving towards
something that we have to see now as
self consciousness so he GLE is in a
certain sense wrapping things up in
these last two paragraphs but in many
ways he's already launching beyond as
we're gonna see especially in the very
last paragraph where he's gonna talk
about being beyond the limit already so
he's doing a little bit of recap here
but he's also introducing some some new
ideas he's saying that the thing that
we're concerned with is infinity the
onion and lika that which does not have
limits or ends or or you know dividing
places to it
and what he's going to say here is that
the understanding is making a bit of a
detour so let's look at the text and
what he's actually saying here in this
he says as the understanding is taking
on this object right as infinity itself
becomes the object of the understanding
the understanding falls short you know
that's the translation that failed here
I'm actually going to call it a detour
it takes a detour from grasping infinity
as such to grasping what it makes of and
and mistakes for this movement of
infinity he says it again a proportions
to two worlds or to two substantial
elements
rather than to one single thing that
encompasses everything the infinite is
it has to be everything it's what we've
been searching for this entire time in
talking about the unconditioned or the
absolute universal but the understanding
has a tendency to want to superimpose
and I'm going to use it this word very
very punning Li its own categories upon
what it's object is so like he says it's
falling short of it it apportions it to
two worlds or two substantial elements
that which is a difference in itself
right we've talked about this quite a
bit difference in itself within
everything there is differentiation
taking place that's also taking place
within the whole within the process that
consciousness is conscious of or
becoming conscious of and is taking
stock of and is also a part of so he
says it again portions that the self the
the the self
repulsion of the self same and the self
attraction of the unlike our this
difference in itself those are two
aspects of it we've seen how this plays
itself out in terms of law in terms of
force in terms of how the understanding
fits in with these we saw the same thing
going on in the previous dialectics that
were parts of the development of
consciousness now we're bringing it all
to a close so that's when understanding
was supposed to get what does it do
instead it shoots towards this something
that it's almost like its own image its
own prompt its own schema by which it's
going to understand infinity and in
doing so it misunderstands it because
what it does is it turns what it is is
living what is developing what is moving
into an inert substance it you know if
we want to pick out somebody to single
out and pick on it would be Aristotle
the Aristotle of the categories who
talks about the Hoople came and on the
subject it's
and translated as the substrate the
thing that that bears qualities and
which doesn't seem to do an awful lot
other than folk you know work as a
repository for these things that we can
call predicates when we predicate
something of something else we're saying
it has this attribute it has this
quality and what we think that we're
doing is designating what that thing is
but we're really only designating a way
in which it is this is the way Aristotle
would talk about it and Hegel wants to
get us away from an over alliance upon
that kind of substance metaphysics and
towards a metaphysics of development of
process it's not to say that he's
totally rejecting substance metaphysics
remember Hegel never really rejects
anything out he thought of you know hand
and says we're gonna banish this to the
you know outer pale or the you know the
outer darkness you know it's totally out
of our scheme instead he says well
there's a one-sidedness to that and we
need to fill in the rest of it so that
we can see the the real truth of what's
going on here that's another important
idea that comes out of this Hegel is
talking about this being the truth that
the understanding has been seeking and
in going after what it takes to be true
in part because it's easier for it it
doesn't grasp the truth at grasp
something else instead so he goes on and
he says so the understanding the
movement as it is found in experience is
here a mere happening movement turns
into something that's more manageable
that the understanding can make sense of
so the self-same of the unlike become
predicates whose essence is in an inert
substance substrate I know nerd subject
whatever you want to call it you know
again Aristotle's Hoople came in on that
which is lying below which the other
stuff is kind of piled on top of what
does this mean that means that this way
of looking at things is in fact a detour
it's
taking us away from the course where we
wanted to be so how do we get back on
course he says what is for the
understanding an object in a sense
sensuous covering is for us in its
essential form as a pure notion pure
concept that's what we're trying to
grasp we're trying to move through the
the world of appearances which we've
seen is also the same as the super
sensuous world of laws and you know
things that seem to be static and the
world of inversion all of those are
rolled into one world so we want to try
to grasp all of this we want to grasp
the essential form as a pure notion he
says the apprehension of the difference
this difference as it is in truth or the
apprehension of infinity as such is for
us or in itself it is not yet in and for
itself it is not yet in and for us
either in that we've realized that we
are part of this very process that
infinity is not something external to
oppose to us the object of our conscious
work but something within which we find
ourselves so there's still some work to
be done here that's why I've got science
or vishton shaft up up here at the top
he says the exposition of its notion
belongs to science science and then he
actually Hegel actually uses exposición
in German you know the cognate the
exposition of the concept the exposition
of the notion the exposition of the big
myth of the living reality of living
intelligibility we might say infinity
that's the job of science as we going to
see him say in the next paragraph that's
not yet done we've got a lot more work
ahead and that's what the next sections
are supposed to be doing so he says
consciousness in the way that it
immediately has this notion because it
does have this notion er this kind
in an implicit way in a way that allows
it to manage within a world that does
have infinity within a world that is in
folded within infinity a world that can
be unpacked over and over again
consciousness can get around it just
doesn't understand what it's doing yet
that's part of what the phenomenology is
supposed to do give us the map to what
it what we've been doing all along and
then help us to see you know where else
we can go and what else has been done by
other consciousnesses that brought us
this far so he says consciousness in the
way that it immediately has this notion
again comes on the scene as a form
belonging to consciousness itself or as
a new shape of consciousness a new dish
Stolte w stein a new a new
transformation something at a higher
level something that's going to
incorporate what has happened before
it's going to - you know transcend it or
sub Laden however you want to translate
of Haven a Haven that's going to lift it
up to a higher level but it's also going
to not quite know what it's doing in the
process so we're just at the cusp of
moving into self-consciousness he says
it doesn't recognize in what has gone
before its own essence it looks on it as
something quite different so
self-consciousness doesn't recognize
that all this other stuff these other
dialectics in sense certainty
you know dialectic of language and
meaning or the language and intention
the immediate and the mediated
perception which led us to you know
grasping things in terms of universals
and in terms of the truth of universals
that the understanding was grasping
finally the entire dialectic of force
and the understanding where the
understanding is in many ways becoming
conscious of just what it does
consciousness doesn't grasp or self
consciousness rather doesn't grasp that
that is part of its very
our own essence but now it's able to
because we've gone through those
passages insofar as we are self
consciousness we get so he says since
this notion of infinity is an object for
consciousness the latter is
consciousness of a difference that is no
less immediately canceled consciousness
is for its own self it is a
distinguishing of that which contains no
difference or self consciousness so we
have this really interesting play here
I get self in the parentheses here we
can also do this as well in talking
about it if we want it to be really
precious and Veridian we might at this
point you know put an A in there and
play around with different difference
but we're not going to do any of that
sort of stuff it's that it's enough just
to focus on what a hill is actually
saying this is a really important point
about self consciousness part of what it
means to be a self consciousness is that
you are not what you are this is
something that Sarge picked up on and
perhaps took a little bit too far turned
into something rather rigid to be self
conscious means to already be
self-transcendent that you grasp that
you are more than what you are and also
to be in a certain sense self primitive
that you are not what you are either
that there is a difference that is no
difference or there is a nothing that is
a difference within the heart of
consciousness itself that's why you can
say I and mean it and that's why I can
grasp your I as the same I and yet a
different eye than the one that I use
we've seen this already before remember
think all the way back to the dialectic
that was going on with Santi we saw the
I fit into this didn't we so this is
part of the essence of
self-consciousness he goes on he says I
distinguished myself for myself and in
doing so
I am directly aware that what is
distinguished from myself is not
different from me I am my memories for
example I am my actions
I am the products of my actions I am my
thoughts I am the complex of habits and
assumptions and relationships that
surround me like sort of a an atmosphere
Zhi Simone says in his book out on
virtue and yet I'm not those things
I'm also and this is a very important
point that's been that you know
signified particularly strongly by
people I can't I am also a sort of
radical freedom a difference from those
right a difference that is not a
difference at the same time this is
really quite amazing stuff isn't it so
he goes on he says it's true
consciousness of an other of an object
in general is necessarily self
consciousness when consciousness has an
object it is at the same time as we've
seen not just consciousness of that
object it is also self consciousness of
itself having that object that is what
it means to actually be conscience this
can be implicit or explicit but it's
still there
whether it's realized or not so he says
the necessary advance from the previous
shapes of consciousness for which their
truth was a thing right again sense
certainty perception the understanding
all oriented towards some thing that is
different than consciousness itself with
the transition from perception to force
in the understanding a little bit of a
glimmer of that but now we're dealing
with self consciousness becoming
conscious of itself as self
consciousness so he goes out and he says
that expresses just this that not only
is consciousness of a thing only
possible for self consciousness but that
self consciousness alone is the truth of
those shapes now does he GLE mean that
animals that don't have a sort of
reflexive self-consciousness or not
conscious of anything he's not saying
that what distinctly human consciousness
is really all
be possible when there's also
self-consciousness you don't get the one
without the other and so he concludes
it's only for us that this truth exists
not yet for consciousness but
self-consciousness has it first become
simply for itself not yet as a unity
with consciousness in general so we have
a whole process lying ahead of us that's
going to be this working out of
self-consciousness and its implications
we see that in the inner world of
appearance the understanding at truth
comes to know nothing else but
appearance but not in the shape of a
play of forces but rather that play of
forces is it's absolutely Universal
moments and in their movement in fact
the understanding experience is only
itself raised above perception
consciousness exhibits itself closed in
a unity with the supersensible
world through the mediating term of
appearance through which it gazes into
this background lying behind appearance
the two extremes of this syllogism the
one of the pure inner world the other of
the intervene gazing into this pure
inner world have now coincided it just
as they quiet streams of vanished so to
the middle term as something other than
these extremes has also vanished this
curtain of appearance hanging before the
inner world is therefore drawn away and
we have the inner being the eye gazing
into the inner world the vision of the
undifferentiated self same being which
repels itself from itself posits itself
as an inner being containing different
moments but for which equally these
moments are immediately not different
self consciousness it is manifest that
behind the so-called curtain which is
supposed to conceal the inner world
there is nothing to be seen unless we go
behind it ourselves
as much as in order that we may see as
that there may be something behind there
which can be seen but at the same time
it is evident that we can not without
more ado go straightaway behind
appearance for this knowledge of what is
the truth of appearance is ordinarily
conceived in of its inner being as
itself only a result of a complex
movement whereby the modes of conscious
meet consciousness meaning perceiving
and the understanding vanish and it will
be equally evident that the cognition of
what consciousness knows in knowing
itself requires a still more complex
movement the exposition of which is
contained in what follows
Henkel now is bringing things completely
to a close as far as the dialectic of
force and the understanding goes and
insofar as he's doing that in this
paragraph 165
he's also bringing an end to the entire
consciousness section our first main
section of the work so he is going to
talk about then you see that I've got
this schema up here a differentiation
between the perspectives of the
understanding which surpasses perception
he's also going to talk about sense
certainty or sense and and meaning -
right the gesturing at the thing and
he's go to the layout this what he calls
you know connection or syllogism between
two terms with a mediating term so he
says we see that in the inner world of
appearance or at the inner world of
appearance appearance already has an
inner to it it's not just something
purely external the understanding and
truth comes to know nothing of the else
but appearance but not in the shape of a
play of forces we've gone beyond that
rather than play of forces in it's
absolutely Universal moments and in
their movement so force law the
understanding itself understanding
itself through using all of these these
intelligible ways of making sense of
things that's all the progress that's
been made so far so he says in fact the
understanding experience is only itself
right so we saw that explanation for
example and the satisfaction that it did
because it's the understanding
explaining things to itself or rather
it's consciousness through the
understanding for doing the explain so
he says raised above perception
consciousness exhibits itself closed in
a unity with a super sensible world
through the mediating term of appearance
again we can't stress this enough
when Hegel distinguishes between these
different worlds is not to create a two
world or
hypothesis where you have the world of
appearances and then the supersensible
world you know eternal laws and then the
inverted world and these are all like
places you could go I'm going to go from
this world to this world of this world
they are all rolled into this world and
what is able to unify them besides the
understanding which actually doesn't
unify them completely as we're going to
see is that they are for consciousness
this is the idealistic aspect of Hegel's
philosophy this is absolute idealism so
he says um through which that through
the mediating term of appearance through
which it gazes into this background
lying behind appearance this background
of what is the you know this is the the
supersensible world however we want to
understand it so he says the two
extremes the one of the pure inner world
the interior of things the the hidden
meaning the recesses of what is we can
understand this in terms of you know the
forces as opposed to just a mere
manifestation of force the laws
structuring things that the
understanding is able to grasp even the
ordinary things don't grasp them they
just follow the laws all that sort of
stuff is is here now the other extreme
me says is the inner being gazing into
this pure inner world
what is that inner being that
intervening is the eye the ego not the
ego in a Freudian sense the ego in the
sense of that which is able to say I
that which takes a position that which
experiences itself as subjectivity
we have reality here we have reality
here and we have something that appears
not to be reality but is also a reality
here as the mediating term it is through
appearance that the inner being is able
to have this relation
of looking into to the pure inner world
and yet as Haney was gonna say these
distinctions are going to collapse
he says they the two extremes have now
coincided how they come excited we've
seen that the inner being itself is in
fact what gives us this pure inner world
so that was it the the world beyond
appearances lies there outside beyond
the you know the appearances which are
themselves external to us and which you
know hinge upon our our senses or
something like that and make their way
into the Citadel of our mind so that
what would be beyond appearance would be
even further away we're able to grasp it
as that which is beyond experience
because we're already there as well this
is a you might say humanized world of
appearances and realities so he goes on
and he says these these extremes ends
extremes have vanished so what does that
mean the middle term also has also
vanished the curtain of appearance
hanging before the inner world is drawn
away doesn't that a wonderful expression
the curtain of appearance is drawn away
so we can see things as they are hanging
hanging before the inner world it's
going we now have the inner being the
eye gazing directly into the inner world
the vision II says of the
undifferentiated self same being which
repels itself from itself ok so this is
all you know the Hegel stuff that we've
come to get to know right the the inner
world is infinity which includes the
self same repelling itself from itself
and the unlike drawing to itself all
this dynamism and movement right and
yeah that's not just in this pure in a
world that is also in the inner being of
the eye that's the really important
movement to grasp here so he says these
movies these moments are not immediately
are immediately not different they are
self-conscious
so he says it's manifest at beyond the
so-called curtain Woodson which is
supposed to conceal the inner world
there's nothing to be seen unless we go
beyond it ourselves this is another way
of saying the same thing repelling the
self-same from itself right you want to
get very hey golly about this by saying
that there's something beyond the
appearances even if we don't completely
have a full understanding we haven't you
know got all the details right about it
we are ourselves placing ourselves as
thinkers as consciousness beyond the
appearances put in more general terms
the way that Hegel likes to talk about
this is that whenever we have a limit if
we think the limit we are already
thinking beyond the limit not
necessarily in a fully explicit way
sometimes you know we just know there's
something there we saw this by the way
with perception right perception grasped
the appearances it's got an inkling that
there's something beyond them it wants
to know what the hell is going on back
there but it's not able to grasp the
truth of it in the way that the
understanding is the understanding does
this by you know means of laws by means
of forces other things as well in a
world the point is whatever is beyond
the appearances whatever is beyond the
limit is already there for us which
means that we're already there but yet
not yet for us not yet realizing that
we're already there that may sound a
little bit complex so let me let me say
that one more time when a little a
little bit differently to when we are
grasping not only that there's a limit
but that there's something beyond the
limit and that what is beyond the limit
matters or is something we'd want to
know we're already to a certain degree
beyond that limit not entirely now down
in a spacial way like we're only here
right but rather we haven't cognized we
haven't made sense of what's on the
other side of the
perhaps because we haven't thought it
through well enough but when we do think
it through we're going to find that we
ourselves are involved in that process
so he says here we go there's nothing to
be seen unless we go beyond it ourselves
in as much in order that we may see as
that there may be something be up behind
there which can be seen we are
responsible for that but at the same
time it's evident we cannot without more
ado go straight away beyond appearance
it's not as if we can say oh well great
problem solved we're done with the
dialectic we've figured it all out know
that we have to go through this process
of working it through working the
concept as Hegel will talk about it and
we have to do so not just as
consciousness fund as self consciousness
so he says this knowledge of what that
what is the truth of appearances
ordinarily conceived in of its inner
being is itself only a result it's not
something we own right now it's not
something that we have at our disposal
unless we you know skip ahead let's get
to the results right but we know that
that's not gonna really work for us if
we're good Hegel yes he says it's not
available for us as result yeah but if
the results of a complex movement we're
by the modes of consciousness meaning
perceiving on the understanding vanish
we're now beyond these in a certain way
we've gone through all that work to now
to sort of put it aside don't feel
disappointed though it's not like we're
totally leaving that stuff behind Hegel
never leaves anything totally behind
you're gonna see that a lot of the same
movements repeating themselves he's
going to talk later on about how these
get recuperated of these get brought
back into the story but he says they
vanished and it would be equally evident
that the cognition of what consciousness
knows and knowing itself requires a
still more complex movement the
exposition of which is contained in what
follows now we're ready to turn the page
and to head into the next section where
we're going to
listen Lee examined self-consciousness
this is a because he says more complex
stage that's really going to be not just
one stage but a sequence of stages which
are going to take us through not only
you know the part that everybody gets
wild about the master-slave dialectic
but also stoicism scepticism and the
unhappy consciousness and get us ready
for further vistas those of reason and
spirit religion and absolute knowing yet
to come